Caption: um we've got Michelle mannering here and
Caption: the title of her talk is GitHub pilot
Caption: using AI to help you learn code and
Caption: build
Caption: it's a bit about Michelle Michelle is a
Caption: highly motivated curious and
Caption: compassionate leader with a keen
Caption: interest in driving entrepreneurial
Caption: culture and pioneering Melbourne's SE
Caption: Sports industry
Caption: she has founded several tech companies
Caption: and as a result sits at the Forefront of
Caption: this City's Science Tech Esports and
Caption: startup scenes
Caption: we're not working at GitHub Michelle
Caption: keeps herself busy as a streamer a
Caption: journalist a quidditch player and a
Caption: conference attendee and is always
Caption: looking to work on something exciting
Caption: thanks Michelle
Caption: thank you thank you everyone so yeah my
Caption: talks titled GitHub co-pilot lots of you
Caption: know or have heard about co-pilot so I
Caption: know you're all here to actually hear
Caption: about co-pilot and not actually to
Caption: listen to me talk but yeah as I said my
Caption: name is Michelle or Mish feel free to
Caption: call me Mish those on my social media
Caption: feel free to follow me I know the
Caption: speaker Bingo is still going so if you
Caption: take some photos of me please tweak them
Caption: I do have a couple of pair of GitHub
Caption: socks to give away as well to some of my
Caption: favorite tweets so tweet them and I'll
Caption: reply to you if you win so I'm a
Caption: developer Advocate at GitHub I've come
Caption: over from Melbourne and yeah really
Caption: exciting to be here and to talk to you
Caption: all about co-pilot
Caption: so today's talk we're going to be
Caption: covering a couple of little things
Caption: before we actually go into the co-pilot
Caption: side of stuff so we talk a little bit
Caption: about the idea of um AI artificial
Caption: intelligence what we're doing in the
Caption: space obviously co-pilot is an AI we're
Caption: going to get to that in a bit
Caption: talk a little bit about the applications
Caption: of AI and how it's relevant today then
Caption: we're obviously going to talk about
Caption: co-pilot and do a little bit of a demo
Caption: I'm going to finish off talking about
Caption: this idea and this concept of ownership
Caption: so first up what is AI now a lot of
Caption: people here have heard about AI it's a
Caption: relatively
Caption: um you know big part of computing and
Caption: it's becoming bigger and bigger as
Caption: becoming smarter and smarter as the name
Caption: suggests now if you Google images of AI
Caption: you'll probably see this kind of stuff
Caption: this you know digital interface you know
Caption: like the whole Ironman Jarvis type stuff
Caption: is is what we kind of see if we start
Caption: googling but what does artificial
Caption: intelligence mean what is the definition
Caption: of artificial intelligence
Caption: now IBM has defined it as this
Caption: which is artificial intelligence
Caption: leverages computers and machines to
Caption: mimic the problem-solving capabilities
Caption: and decision making of people
Caption: so this definition has been
Caption: refined over the years originally AI
Caption: came out of like the Turing project and
Caption: then it's kind of moved into more about
Caption: okay well now it's um you know machine
Caption: learning we're all about training models
Caption: but now we're getting into this more
Caption: stage of artificial intelligence and
Caption: back in the day when I first started
Caption: doing um startups one of my first
Caption: startups was actually an AI company you
Caption: see a lot of AI staffs thinking oh yeah
Caption: we're doing artificial intelligence
Caption: you're like sweet what are you doing
Caption: they're like this this and this you're
Caption: like yeah that's not AI that's actually
Caption: machine learning so machine learning
Caption: itself is training the model and
Caption: teaching the things AI is now into that
Caption: more decision making process what have I
Caption: learned and what can I then use to solve
Caption: this problem
Caption: so that's where the difference is in AI
Caption: and machine learning now I think movies
Caption: are a really really good way to think
Caption: about the concepts of these kind of like
Caption: future Tech now when we used to talk
Caption: about you know what's future technology
Caption: going to look like oh look at movies
Caption: like Back to the Future and minority
Caption: Porter and wonder when that's going to
Caption: come in and literally the other day I
Caption: was having a conversation with my
Caption: housemate and he's like you know with
Caption: all this stuff you're doing really not
Caption: that far away from java so you might
Caption: we're actually already here
Caption: um this whole idea of java is this
Caption: machine not the physical part not the
Caption: alternate side of it but the original
Caption: Iron Man side of it
Caption: um you know the 19 whatever movie it was
Caption: now in the back in the 90s this whole
Caption: idea of training this system with lots
Caption: of data points and it can now tell us
Caption: what to do
Caption: it can give us information from all this
Caption: understanding and all this stuff that
Caption: we've trained it on
Caption: for example everyone's seen this hey
Caption: Siri
Caption: now when hey Siri and Google and Alexa
Caption: when they started they were kind of like
Caption: glorified search engines hey Siri how
Caption: long is the Great Wall of China who's
Caption: who's old enough to remember that NBN ad
Caption: or the Internet Ad hey Dad why did they
Caption: build a Great Wall of China oh yeah to
Caption: keep the rabbits out
Caption: and the whole thing was like give your
Caption: kids the right answer so Siri when it
Caption: started was this glorified search engine
Caption: now it's a bit more hey you know people
Caption: always say oh you know your phone's
Caption: listening into you well yeah it is
Caption: because it's trying to understand and
Caption: learn so now it doesn't just give you
Caption: information that you need to know it
Caption: says oh I've also noticed that um you
Caption: played golf the other day do you need
Caption: some more golf balls because you are
Caption: might have lost it for you
Caption: so another one is um Google Nest now I
Caption: see this idea of the connected home the
Caption: connected devices Google Nest now uses
Caption: artificial intelligence to you in their
Caption: cameras to see if there's Intruders in
Caption: your house which is I think kind of cool
Caption: so it's built up an image recognition of
Caption: who you are and it's now learned who you
Caption: are as a person it can now detect other
Caption: people in the house then send you a
Caption: thing saying hey we think someone else
Caption: is in your house based on the movement
Caption: patterns of you and this other person
Caption: that we don't recognize we think there's
Caption: someone in your house is there some some
Caption: of the applications there
Caption: who drives a car here pretty much
Caption: everyone
Caption: now everyone's like when self-driving
Caption: cars coming out I'm like well Ai and
Caption: machine learning has been in cars for a
Caption: while this idea of not just power assist
Caption: but now I've got driver assist
Caption: you know traction controls off you know
Caption: you stay in the lanes get off the road
Caption: or stay on the road rather this idea of
Caption: driver assist right
Caption: and people like oh yes I can start
Caption: seeing it in our daily lives what about
Caption: technology
Caption: I came across this one the other day
Caption: called
Caption: um what was it called
Caption: um I can't remember the name of it
Caption: hasn't put about up here but there's a
Caption: there's a machine learning and AI
Caption: algorithm it's in my um resource at the
Caption: end they actually write articles for you
Caption: so you don't even need to be a
Caption: journalist anymore and outside my job at
Caption: GitHub I'm a journalist and I'm like oh
Caption: geez
Caption: um the computers are coming from my job
Caption: um but yeah they can they can write
Caption: articles
Caption: um there's a really really contentious
Caption: thing that popped up the other day a lot
Caption: of people probably seen it this idea of
Caption: artwork there's a famous U.S art prize
Caption: that went out and it ended up going to a
Caption: person who uses um use computer
Caption: generated imagery to create the artwork
Caption: now what I think is really cool about
Caption: the artwork side of things and we're
Caption: going to get to it in a little bit is
Caption: the more specific you give more
Caption: parameters that you give the the engine
Caption: the better artwork you're going to make
Caption: and I made that one on mid-journey just
Caption: the other day
Caption: and so if you type in some fun things
Caption: you might get something back you're like
Caption: oh that's a bit weird it's not the
Caption: computer or the system not um like
Caption: giving you something somebody well it's
Caption: a little bit dumb isn't it like well no
Caption: you just haven't told it what you want
Caption: now we're starting to see it in
Caption: programming we're starting to see this
Caption: idea of not just glorified search
Caption: engines coming in to help you
Caption: but programs that are coming in to help
Caption: you code
Caption: and if you have a look again it's going
Caption: to be um there's a link at the end with
Caption: a bunch of resources there's the top 10
Caption: AI pair program or AI systems plugins
Caption: that you can use for vs code
Caption: one of them is Ali AI which helps you
Caption: understand what you've written
Caption: yeah because because you need you need
Caption: to know that as a developer what kind of
Caption: code have I written here I actually was
Caption: talking to someone the other day of
Caption: dinner and they're like yeah sometimes
Caption: you just don't know what you're right
Caption: and I'm like that's where an AI pair
Caption: program would help now on that list they
Caption: obviously have GitHub co-pilot as one of
Caption: the top AI extensions that you can use
Caption: in vs code
Caption: so what is GitHub Copilot
Caption: GitHub copilot is your AI pair
Caption: programmer this is there to help you
Caption: build write and understand your code
Caption: better
Caption: like the other extensions in vs code
Caption: it's built right into your editor and
Caption: you can use it to help you write code
Caption: now if we have a look at it here this is
Caption: um a little quick example of it it's
Caption: built on the AI open codex some of my
Caption: slides are actually back to front here
Caption: but it's built on the AI codex I should
Caption: have used Ai and copilot to write my
Caption: slide deck but yeah it's built on AI
Caption: codex it's trained on billions of lines
Caption: of code you can see here it's suggesting
Caption: this whole function
Caption: but unlike some of it's um predecessors
Caption: or pre-existing uh AI features and AI
Caption: functionality
Caption: it's not just autocomplete
Caption: it is not just saying looking at it
Caption: going well hang on I think I know what
Caption: you're going to write so let me
Caption: auto-complete that for you we're having
Caption: this conversation over dinner the other
Caption: night and it was like oh isn't that the
Caption: whole idea of like reducing the amount
Caption: of keystrokes that you make and I was
Caption: like well not really because you can
Caption: either just learn a type faster or you
Caption: can use shortcuts like the whole idea
Caption: isn't just reducing the amount of
Caption: keystrokes it should be about being
Caption: better programmers and actually writing
Caption: better code
Caption: so that's what profiler does
Caption: and it doesn't just provide you with
Caption: Snippets of code doesn't just say oh you
Caption: know you want to write this thing here's
Caption: a snippet of code and you know I'm going
Caption: to give you the same snippet of code and
Caption: give you the same snippety code you can
Caption: view the same snippity code no it
Caption: doesn't do that it actually uses
Caption: what you've currently got in your file
Caption: and what it knows about the language
Caption: that you're writing and uses that
Caption: context I'm saying before about if the
Caption: more parameters that you give it uses
Caption: the context of what you're trying to do
Caption: to actually synthesize code that's
Caption: specific for you so if we all go use
Caption: Copart right now we're all going to get
Caption: very very different responses when we
Caption: start using it which I think is really
Caption: cool
Caption: one of the other ways it differs from
Caption: some of its pre-existing models is just
Caption: the sheer scale of co-pilot
Caption: when we work with machine learning and
Caption: we're using machine learning to train
Caption: artificial intelligent models
Caption: one of the things that we need is lots
Caption: and lots of data points
Caption: have you heard of like the phrase
Caption: dodgy data in dodgy data out
Caption: so what we've done is we haven't just
Caption: put dodgy data into it we've used data
Caption: we've used really good quality data to
Caption: train the model but we've also used
Caption: literally billions and billions of data
Caption: points lots and lots of code to train
Caption: this model
Caption: so it is an AI pair programmer you can
Caption: sit down and code with and again our
Caption: same conversation of having my housemate
Caption: who isn't actually in technology he's
Caption: like oh it's coming to like from why
Caption: you're describing it it's kind of like
Caption: you sitting there
Caption: writing code and it's like having a
Caption: senior developer working next year and I
Caption: was like well yeah but it's like having
Caption: like 83 million developers senior
Caption: developers working next to you not that
Caption: everyone using GitHub as a scene in
Caption: developer but you're basically using the
Caption: collective knowledge of the internet
Caption: to then help you write code which I
Caption: think is really cool I mean that's one
Caption: of the coolest things about us being
Caption: able to sit down and um you know where
Caption: we've come now in history right we're
Caption: able to use the collective knowledge of
Caption: everyone else who came before us so why
Caption: can't we use that every single day while
Caption: we code
Caption: and one of the things I really like
Caption: about the co-pilot too is it's not
Caption: really limited to any particular person
Caption: right you know Damon did a fantastic
Caption: talk before I'm like code spaces and
Caption: actions and all this kind of cool stuff
Caption: like yeah that's so cool you know but
Caption: some of it when you start getting it
Caption: deep I'm like oh it's kind of beyond my
Caption: knowledge
Caption: but we Corey pilot pretty much every
Caption: single person can use it whether you're
Caption: a developer that's just starting out or
Caption: you're a senior developer working on
Caption: Facebook or Instagram or whatever you're
Caption: doing that's what I really like about it
Caption: so here's a little snippet from our
Caption: website so you can see it works in
Caption: multiple languages well
Caption: so we have lots of different languages
Caption: you can use copilot with
Caption: and you can see a little bit in a demo
Caption: about the different types of ways you
Caption: can use those languages
Caption: and what I really like about too is it
Caption: doesn't just provide you with code that
Caption: it thinks you need it provides you with
Caption: really really meaningful code based on
Caption: the context that you've got
Caption: all right let's get into a demo there's
Caption: a couple of spoilers in there so I was
Caption: like well let's not talk about those now
Caption: let's talk about the demo right so in
Caption: this demo this is pre-recorded but it's
Caption: mine I did this myself like literally
Caption: two days ago one of the reasons I did it
Caption: pre-recorded is we don't have a lot of
Caption: time we literally have like 20 minutes
Caption: uh the second reason is because copilot
Caption: learns
Caption: it means that when I finish writing the
Caption: code already knows I'm going to write
Caption: what I want so I'm going to show you in
Caption: a minute but basically if you haven't
Caption: used GitHub profile before you need to
Caption: go to the vs code extension Marketplace
Caption: you're going to grab Copilot reinstall
Caption: it
Caption: you log into GitHub
Caption: like use your credentials to log in
Caption: and then you allow it and then you can
Caption: start using Copilot
Caption: so you can see down the bottom there
Caption: that little co-pilot icon there
Caption: so when we're using it this is an
Caption: example
Caption: um that I wrote the other day
Caption: I was on twilio Quest trying to do one
Caption: of their coding challenges and I got a
Caption: little bit stuck and I was like hahaha I
Caption: can use co-pilot and I was doing this
Caption: live on a twitch stream as well so what
Caption: I'm providing up there is um basically
Caption: the um the problem that it was asking me
Caption: to solve and interestingly enough even
Caption: though I wrote that out as a comment to
Caption: start off with it tried to give me a
Caption: function so what
Caption: the um the problem there is basically it
Caption: reverse the sentence all the letters
Caption: need to be non-capitalized unless it's
Caption: the name of something the first letter
Caption: of the word of the reverse sentence
Caption: needs to be capitalized and the
Caption: punctuation needs to go at the end so
Caption: obviously when I wrote oh we need to
Caption: reverse the sentence it just gave me one
Caption: function it says reverse a sentence I
Caption: was like okay copilot needs more context
Caption: here
Caption: so what I'm writing out and this is what
Caption: I did on my stream I was like all right
Caption: what are the steps that I need to go
Caption: through to solve this problem let's
Caption: write them out and plain English each
Caption: step that I need to do so I'm here I'm
Caption: going okay first let's actually make the
Caption: first letter of the sentence lower case
Caption: if it's not an I I had a bunch of
Caption: sentences and I was like let's not not
Caption: worry about like names of places let's
Caption: just start a little bit basic with an
Caption: iron so I was like okay
Caption: um okay Copart let's see what you can
Caption: give me and I was like all right let's
Caption: um change a couple little parameters
Caption: here
Caption: just to make it a little bit easier to
Caption: understand
Caption: but
Caption: by providing co-pilot with the context
Caption: and the way that I want to solve this
Caption: problem it's able to help me better than
Caption: the original
Caption: um snippet of code that it gave me which
Caption: is reverse a sentence I'm like well
Caption: that's great if I just want to reverse
Caption: the sentence but I knew how to do that
Caption: um so let's go through these on so I was
Caption: like right next we want to split the
Caption: sentence into an array of words because
Caption: we actually want to reverse this
Caption: sentence
Caption: so it's like all right that's there and
Caption: I'm like oh sweet that's pretty good too
Caption: and I'm sitting there going tab tab tab
Caption: while I'm live streaming this thing
Caption: which is pretty cool I was like I don't
Caption: have to do anything here yeah Copart
Caption: really is going to take my job uh
Caption: provides with all the punctuation marks
Caption: there but I was like oh no I want to
Caption: make sure that um this the words yeah
Caption: there you go
Caption: pretty pretty cool hey
Caption: um so yeah I was like all right now
Caption: let's take out the punctuation marks
Caption: from the sentence and what I want to do
Caption: is I want to store them still so I could
Caption: add them back in later which is why I'm
Caption: um adding the array there I was like
Caption: right now I'm going to remove them so
Caption: right there it is let's uh replace the
Caption: punctuation marks there with um with
Caption: nothing at the end
Caption: um so I was like oh I'm going to call it
Caption: a sentence because that's going to be
Caption: easy and then obviously last thing we
Caption: want to do is we want to
Caption: um
Caption: uh split no obviously we've done this
Caption: now let's split the center reverse the
Caption: sentence here come on gee I'm typing
Caption: really slow on it
Caption: um let's reverse the sentence join it
Caption: back together again and add the
Caption: punctuation marks at the end I was like
Caption: sweet
Caption: um what are you gonna give me okay
Caption: that's a pretty good copilot
Caption: um so let's let's name that there and I
Caption: was like sweet
Caption: I basically have most of my stuff there
Caption: thanks to copilot
Caption: um changed a couple little parameters as
Caption: you can see I had a help from a
Caption: developer who's a lot more senior than
Caption: me
Caption: um doing this on stream but yeah this
Caption: was like really cool that copilot's able
Caption: to do this now I was like finally yeah
Caption: we need to add the punctuation marks
Caption: back into the sentence and we need to
Caption: actually join it back together so you
Caption: can see here it's trying to predict what
Caption: I'm asked like what it wants to do but
Caption: I'm like providing with a little bit
Caption: more context each time we can see their
Caption: Bang
Caption: it's provided that with me and I was
Caption: like that's really cool again let's
Caption: double check that with um some code that
Caption: a senior developer gave me and I was
Caption: like well that's exactly what he wrote
Caption: basically I think copilot's come for
Caption: your job mate
Caption: um no I'm just kidding but basically
Caption: it's it's really awesome it's able to
Caption: provide with a lot of context and I'll
Caption: give you a couple of quotes here these
Caption: are straight off our website
Caption: um but yeah like people are just
Caption: absolutely loving
Caption: um what co-pilot does so it is pretty
Caption: awesome and it's like actually
Caption: mind-blowing um the technology it does
Caption: now as I was saying before one of the
Caption: reasons why I didn't want to do this
Caption: live is because when you are writing
Caption: co-pilot and you can see there we went
Caption: through all the stuff
Caption: copart's learning
Caption: it's learning what you want it to do and
Caption: for you so I was like okay what happens
Caption: if I had have done this live something
Caption: like this probably would have happened
Caption: so open up a brand new file copy and
Caption: paste that same bit in there and Copart
Caption: goes oh yeah I think I know what you're
Caption: trying to do
Caption: um I reckon you're trying to reverse a
Caption: sentence and bang
Caption: the whole thing I was like that's what
Caption: would have happened if we had done this
Caption: live and you wouldn't have got that cool
Caption: like that you know the suspense of each
Caption: part you know breaking down the uh the
Caption: problem and understanding how to
Caption: actually do that so thanks to that one
Caption: co-file that was really cool
Caption: now people really like this and again my
Caption: the title my talk isn't just using
Caption: copilot to code it's using copilot to
Caption: actually understand
Caption: um and learn with your code not just It
Caption: Loan right
Caption: so I will launched just new things
Caption: shortly after copilot called GitHub
Caption: co-pilot Labs you get another extension
Caption: so you go to the vs Marketplace install
Caption: that in there and then you'll see this
Caption: little pop-up on the side of your vs
Caption: code called Copart Labs now what I like
Caption: about copilot Labs is it actually helps
Caption: you again the same function here it
Caption: actually helps you especially if you're
Caption: starting and running
Caption: I actually hope to explain and
Caption: understand your code now again someone
Caption: was you know you're kind of laughing at
Caption: me before you wrote the code though
Caption: don't you understand it not always what
Caption: happens if I opened up this in a code
Caption: space or forked forked um some code from
Caption: someone else or claimed a repo what I
Caption: can do now is I can now highlight parts
Caption: of code and get co-pilot to actually
Caption: explain what's going on here
Caption: so co-pilot again if I click um if I
Caption: keep clicking ask it'll try and explain
Caption: it in a different way kind of like a
Caption: teacher it's like I didn't quite
Caption: understand first time what we'll try
Caption: again
Caption: um and it gives you a bunch of different
Caption: options to actually explain your code so
Caption: you can explain it in plain English yes
Caption: this is a function design or you know to
Caption: see if the first letter of the character
Caption: in the sentence is actually an i if not
Caption: then it'll change it you can actually
Caption: get it to explain it in um more in-depth
Caption: English so like slightly longer and then
Caption: you can also get it to explain it to you
Caption: in terms of like the syntax what parts
Caption: of the function being called and then
Caption: finally you can actually get it to give
Caption: you
Caption: um an example what would actually happen
Caption: talked about this last night dinner as
Caption: well the idea of actually translating
Caption: your code this is still something we're
Caption: working on so it's not perfect but you
Caption: can actually translate your code into
Caption: other languages so if you're a python
Caption: developer and just wanting to learn
Caption: something else like it's a ruby PHP
Caption: whatever you can now get it to try and
Caption: help you translate your code now
Caption: obviously it's not perfect and see a
Caption: couple of you sneaking there in the
Caption: corner uh it's not perfect it's not um
Caption: it's not great we're getting there
Caption: um but yeah have a look at that
Caption: um so somebody asked me the other day
Caption: I'm nearly wrapping up but what happens
Caption: if I actually don't want co-pilot to use
Caption: the stuff that I've got to learn
Caption: um what if also it does it because
Caption: copied ever actually give us the same
Caption: um piece of code
Caption: because it's still a relatively new
Caption: model and you know what we're still
Caption: doing we're still learning
Caption: you can actually get co-pilot to filter
Caption: out some of the things that it can tell
Caption: you so in most cases the code that
Caption: Copart gives you is specific to you it's
Caption: been synthesized just for you in less
Caption: than one percent of the cases however
Caption: you might get code that is similar to
Caption: something that is already in an open
Caption: source repository so you can turn off
Caption: the filter in your copilot settings on
Caption: GitHub and say actually block these
Caption: suggestions so if there's a snippet of
Caption: code that's even you know 100 characters
Caption: I can't remember exactly what it is but
Caption: about 100 characters similar to another
Caption: piece of code that's on the internet
Caption: don't show it to me and then under that
Caption: you also saw there was that um option to
Caption: say do not use my code
Caption: um for improving github's products so
Caption: your code won't be yours if you like
Caption: profile head over to the copilot website
Caption: copilot.com
Caption: and try it out
Caption: it is free for 60 days for anyone to try
Caption: otherwise Ingress is 120 dollars
Caption: for the year something like that
Caption: ten dollars a month and then and a
Caption: hundred for a year so you get you know
Caption: two months free if you sign up for the
Caption: whole year teachers I've just found out
Caption: if you're a teacher you now get Copart
Caption: for free as part of the um campus
Caption: program the GitHub Global Campus program
Caption: it's a teacher you get it for free
Caption: and obviously open source developers um
Caption: you get that um for free as well working
Caption: on a big open source project now finally
Caption: I know where um at time but finally I
Caption: really want to touch on this point of
Caption: ownership because it comes up all the
Caption: time
Caption: um regardless of whether it's the
Caption: articles that we're talking about before
Caption: the artwork
Caption: um here with program people like what
Caption: happens with you know AI like ownership
Caption: who owns the thing do I own it because I
Caption: you know built the artwork does the
Caption: program own it because they're the ones
Caption: who built the AI there's the open AI own
Caption: it most of the time we've come to the
Caption: conclusion that nearly all these things
Caption: they they allow the people who actually
Caption: create it to have the ownership and it's
Caption: exactly the same with co-pilot so the
Caption: code that you write with copilot is your
Caption: code nobody else owns it we don't own it
Caption: you own it so I want to finish on that
Caption: finally again there's a gist up there
Caption: for all the resources links to
Caption: everything
Caption: um that I spoke about if you do have
Caption: questions because obviously you don't
Caption: have time for questions and I never
Caption: included time for questions you can
Caption: tweet me on all the social media
Caption: platforms notes man or come chat to us
Caption: at the booth because I have a couple
Caption: persons ask your way thank you so much
Caption: for listening to me co-pilot in 20
Caption: minutes
Caption: thank you so much